Bob:
This is the Land of Luck.
It’s so wonderful to think
outside of what we know.
And to entertain the thoughts
that there is more
Eva:
and that there is bigger and
that there is deeper and there is wider.
We don’t live in a world without
storytelling.
Whoopi:
And that’s the thing that keeps
the world going.
Films can expand what’s
possible and expand the
imagination and
can open peoples hearts and
minds.
Luck, it’s incredibly uplifting
and it’s incredibly positive.
Is he thoughtful or what?
And the concept just seemed
utterly bananas.
Luck is all about Sam, the
unluckiest girl in the world.
-Oh!
-Uhh..
Sorry to bother you.
Ouch! How did it get on your..
Peggy:
Who journeys to the never before
seen Land of Luck
Peggy:
and discovers really what good
luck is all about.
Sam:
Oww!
Eva
The Land of Luck is
in charge of creating and
randomly distributing luck both
good and bad to the human world.
The luck you create today could
change a life tomorrow.
It’s magical. It’s the land of
luck,
Whoopi:
but it's organized.
Now drop your pennies and move
along.
Say captain, do you like
jokes?
Only the funny ones Bob.
(Laughing)
Right.
Bob is this very mischievous
not entirely professional
worker in the Land of Luck.
Hey Bob, everything ok?
Aye just uh, stretching my legs.
Okie dokie.
Sam accidentally goes through
the portal with Bob.
Aww!
What kind of a crazy talking cat
are you?
A lucky Scottish one obviously.
Several things are very
critical.
Jane:
One is to keep good luck and bad
luck separated.
The tiniest amount of bad luck
can shut down our entire
operation.
Another is human beings cannot
set foot in the Land of Luck.
What could go wrong?
(Boys & Girls)
Aww!
I love animation as a way of
storytelling because it is so
collaborative.
Peggy:
And then you get to sort of
create the world.
Peggy:
You actually create the soul of
the characters.
(Gasp)
Jeff’s a unicorn!?
(Screaming)
Ah, Oh you surprised my heart to
stop.
The very, very first week on the
movie when I was trying, we were
trying
to sort of think about what
should this story be.
Peggy:
I asked the artists in the art
department
and all the story artists to
just literally for three days
come up with drawings
Peggy:
of good luck creatures and bad
luck creatures.
Peggy:
Based on research we had done.
on sort of international lucky
icons from all over the world.
Along with lucky numbers, lucky
colors, we had done a huge
amount of research.
And that was their first
assignment, just go crazy.
Luck is actually sort of an
abstract idea right?
Ernie:
So the biggest challenge was
coming up with a world that represented that idea.
Luck is very universal, but very
different in different cultures.
So immediately the leprechaun
came to mind.
Clarisse:
As well as the four leaf
clovers
Clarisse:
and the pig.
Ernie:
The Land of Luck it’s a world of
synchronicity.
Ernie:
It’s just really fun to watch
there’s a choreography to it.
If it wasn’t a lucky place it
would actually be quite
treacherous.
Ernie:
And it is for Sam.
Oww!
♪♪
Just how unlucky are you?
Yeah, super duper.
Peggy:
This is an animated film but
these actors
invested 500% on what is their
character.
Sam is wonderfully determined
and she is, I think extremely
optimistic.
Ok Universe, you think you’re
pretty tough?
Eva:
Her luck hinders her.
But nevertheless, she persists.
Simon:
Eva, just really gets to the
heart of that character.
Take that universe.
She’s utterly delightful and you
root for her so much.
I found an actual lucky penny
and what did I do?
I flushed it down the toilet!
You did what!?
You flushed my lucky penny down
the toilet!?
Simon is a legend.
Eva:
He is a comedic genius and he
brings so much life to Bob.
What manner of crazy human are
you?
Simon:
To play this sort of guide into
that world,
it just, it felt like a gift.
Eva:
Bob knows the Land of Luck
inside out.
Eva:
He has good ideas.
Eva
Together they create the perfect
team with determination and execution.
We lucky ladies of stature ought
to stick together don’t ya
think?
Jane Fonda as a dragon when they
told me I was like,
perfect casting, check mark, I
love you.
I mean it’s not everyday you get
a chance to voice a dragon...
Aww!
Jane:
...named Babe. (chuckle)
I just thought that was so much
fun.
(Sirens & tires skidding)
Bob:
Ah! It’s the captain!
I love animation, so anytime
someone asks me
Whoopi:
if I want to do an animation
I say yes.
I love Whoopi,
she’s a fantastic actor and has
a brilliant comedic sensibility
as well.
Wasn’t funny.
You’ve not really seen a black
leprechaun before.
I haven’t, and I’ve met many.
Simon:
This is one of those kinds of
films where you have to watch it once
just to take it in and then
you can sort of concentrate
on the story.
Eva:
Sam goes on this wonderful
journey of
discovering that just because
she’s clumsy or things break or
things don’t work out
it doesn’t mean it’s her fault.
Oww!
Sam:
Bad luck led me to the luckiest
thing in the world or was it good luck?
Love is the luckiest thing in
the world.
So I really wanted to tell that
story that everybody can feel
the love
your forever family can look
different.
♪♪
It’s just a lovely story about
the importance of friendship and
family
Simon:
and it’s a rip roaring adventure
as well.
I like the idea that we’re
changing hearts and minds
through this.
Jane:
The important message is don't
give up.
Jane:
Don’t ever give up.
Because you don’t know what the
future might hold.
Eva:
This movie brings humanity into
the idea of making mistakes.
You can’t plan everything to go
well
Eva:
and when you fall you pick
yourself up again,
Eva:
that's life.
♪♪